[Music]
wait you have a good heart what's
training you can be expelled
I have not x-men material at all first
off I'm not even a virgin
I let the cable kill this kid but I
can't do this alone
I'm an expert
Upton Bieber he called you Justin Bieber
you're no hero you're just a clown
dressed up as a toy
my name is cable I'm here for the kid
kids give us a chance to be better than
we used to be he needs you daddy's got
this I let you cable get to him but I
can't do this alone I need your help
ladies understatement of the year you're
absolutely right
oh wait this guy gave him a chance
[Applause]
it's cable filipok use all of your
imaginary powers
Oh God he's inside and hear yourself
bright accidental double entendre
[Music]
hey everybody its charlie we got a bunch
of new Deadpool to break down lady
Deadpool and Ryan Reynolds revealed that
there have already been a couple of ban
jokes that he had to take out of the
movie before release it wouldn't be a
Deadpool movie if some of it didn't get
censored so I'll explain what's going on
in the stuff that they had to take out
but if you're finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get all the
Marvel videos there'll be a bunch of
Deadpool dropping really soon and we
still have a whole bunch of Avengers
infinity war and Avengers force stuff to
talk about there in the middle of the
press tour for Deadpool so naturally
Ryan Reynolds is going all over the
world doing interviews about the movie
he revealed that Fox forced him to take
out some disney jokes from the movie
because of the pending merger so
naturally you know Disney's buying out
Fox we're all really excited because
that means look at the x-men characters
but while the corporate people at Fox
are totally cool with him making jokes
about the DC Universe so dark are you
sure you're not from the DC Universe
they apparently don't want him taking
too many direct shots at the House of
mouse they were probably jokes about the
Disney brand itself how family-friendly
it is and Mickey Mouse himself but
remember they said that the Disney jokes
had been banned from the movie not the
Marvel joke so there's still plenty of
Thanos you don't have the stones to help
me out with this kind of stuff so of
course there are plenty of shots taken
at the Marvel movies at the DC movies
it's just the Disney stuff that we won't
see in the way he talked about it made
it sound like that stuff will not wind
up on the DVD because some stuff just
gets cut for time like oh we just you
know we didn't have time or we're
riffing like the Deadpool bloopers that
I posted a long time ago I'll add a link
for that at the end of this that's just
them riffing and then picking the best
take this is something different this is
like Fox actually saying no no no you
can't do this you have to take this
completely out of the film but let's
talk about that new footage the funny
stuff here though is that it actually
shows him trying to join x-men proper
and becoming an official trainee that's
why he's wearing that yellow x-men
Jersey so obviously that's from the
comics they're been briefed times when
he's flirted with the idea of joining
the x-men they even posted this funny
promo the other day where Deadpool had
sent a letter to the Avengers to try and
join them it was signed by Tony Stark
he's like no no no absolutely not call
Professor X I would just expect more of
that kind of stuff
while they're dropping all these
trailers just because infinity ward's
blowing up so they're pretty easy target
for Deadpool to take shots at the funny
thing though is as the Deadpool has been
a member of the Avengers longer than
he's been a member of the x-men at any
given time during the comics there was a
period a little while ago when he was
funding the Avengers because he had you
know quote/unquote sold out so much they
turned it into a bit of a joke in the
comics when the first movie blew up a
couple of years ago back in 2016 so
Deadpool in the comics sold out made a
ton of money and because Tony Stark at
the time did not have a lot of money
Deadpool became the person that was
funding the Avengers we get to see him
wheeling around the x-mansion in
Professor X's chair just knocking over
statues and all kinds of stuff I'm sure
there'll be plenty of Easter eggs in the
background with the way they decorated
that x-mansion we get a shot of Russell
aka fire fist making fun of negasonic
calling her Justin Bieber just because
of the way she looks in the movie they
said that his codename is just hot stuff
so he just sounds like Deadpool coins
the name and that's what they call him
for the rest of the movie we get that DC
joke again I'm sure they're gonna put
that in most of the trailers it was
actually a whole bunch of news about
that new DC streaming service that the
TV shows they're rolling out Deadpool is
mostly making fun of the movies though
we get a new shot of him talking to
negasonic and Serge this is probably
before he becomes an x-men trainee like
he needs a team so he probably goes to
the x-mansion first then he probably
gets the idea to put x-force together
but this shot of him in the strip club
with the blonde wig on is a lady
Deadpool Easter Egg if you're not a big
Deadpool comic book fan lady Deadpool is
a female version of Deadpool from
another universe so her name is Wanda
Wilson so it's literally the Deadpool
character just genderbent
from an alternate universe she's a
relatively new addition to the Deadpool
Canon considering the Deadpool character
debuted back during the early 90s she
debuted during Merc with the mouth
number 7 in 2010 so not super old
compared to a lot of these other x-men
characters like in most movies you have
the classic roster the Avengers movies
classic Avengers the x-men movies
classic x-men pretty understandable that
is we get more movies in the next 10
years a lot of the characters will have
to be more recent additions just because
you've already done all those classic
characters you get the Domino clip just
showing you how her powers work with a
whole bunch of double
aunt Andris she does the same overpass
jump the Deadpool did from the first
movie making that really tough landing
through the small skylight easily kicks
the guard out the door disarming him
spinning the rearview mirror around so
that she gets a shot up cable chasing
after them Deadpool is on his scooter
which is also from the comics if you
didn't know Deadpool does write a red
scooter like this in the comics then it
just turns into Deadpool's double
entendre she winds up going to the back
to fight him but he you know he says
he's on top of you he's coming in
through the back everybody knows what
that means
so eventually like later in the trailers
that we've seen so far she just goes
back and starts fighting cable in the
back of that truck but the thing here
too is that you actually get a shot of
Deadpool trying to make that save so it
one reminds you of what Deadpool's
powers are because the movie kind of
treats him like he's rubber like you can
shoot him you can chop his limbs off he
can bounce off of things get in big car
wrecks but he bounces right back so he's
like a really big rubber action figure
that soaks damage interesting fact
though he actually feels all that so
even though he's gonna heal all that
damage it still hurts like a [ __ ] if
she would have been standing on the back
of that truck he would have made that
save so you get a good sense for the
physics of her ability so like if she
wants to be able to help the rest of
x-force out and give them good luck they
have to be standing relatively close in
formation but like I said this is the
beginning of the Deadpool press tour
it's not coming out for a couple more
weeks so there'll be more of this funny
kind of stuff obviously I'll do videos
for anything if it drops but leave all
your Deadpool video requests in the
comments below and I know they've been a
lot of questions about what's gonna
happen with the Deadpool character when
Kevin Feige gets access to all the
characters in a couple years still gonna
take a couple years for the dust to
settle on all this even though the deal
is supposed to be completed by the end
of next summer Ryan Reynolds said that
the character would always come back at
least in team-based movies but he's not
so sure what's gonna happen to the
future of the Solow Deadpool movies so
instead of doing Deadpool 3 after the
x-force movie which is coming out next
year sometime like they're actually
supposed to shoot x-force at the end of
this year it's supposed to be released
in 2019 at some point they might just do
another x-force movie with Deadpool
instead of going back to Deadpool 3 and
alternating between x-force and Deadpool
movies but for the most part I don't
think the Disney deal is going to
affect Deadpool that much in Bob Iger
already said that the Disney streaming
service is mostly gonna be non r-rated
content all of the r-rated content that
Disney is gonna get access to through
this Fox deal he's just gonna go to Hulu
so if you have Hulu that's where all the
Deadpool and more hardcore x-men Marvel
related stuff is going to go when they
get that IP so no worries there what's
gonna happen next is I have a new arrow
episode video that I'm working on and
then there'll be some new Marvel this
weekend the infinity war directors also
confirm my soul gem theory so you can
actually click here for my last big
Avengers video and click here to rewatch
all those banned deadpool jokes thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]